i also had no [ __ ] clue what sashimi
was until i first came here a lot of
people seriously
no seriously no a lot of people don't
because i i didn't know there was a
choice we could just
get rid of the rice
i guess it's like a steak without like
the sides right like i could just have a
steak
and i thought like oh i mean yeah i
guess
i mean it i will admit right i wanted to
be that guy who immediately loved
sashimi and sushi and i was like dude i
[ __ ] love this
yeah yeah but it took me a while to get
used to it and really get like
into it and appreciate like the taste of
it because when i first had sashimi i'm
like
yeah it doesn't taste good really yeah
yeah yeah it was definitely something
that grew on me because i remember i
went most of my childhood
um hating sushi and hating sashimi
because i was like
raw fish why do i want to eat raw and in
the uk they do that [ __ ] dirty bro yeah
yo sushi truth
like i had like this one day where i
just
for some reason i was like man that kind
of looks
appetizing let me let me give that a
shot right and then after that after the
first time when i was an adult and i
tried sushi again i was like
i [ __ ] love this [ __ ] i love the
taste of raw fish tastes amazing
and having sushi in japan it's just the
quality of the fish
is just so damn good that even if you go
to like
one of those dollar places where you can
get like you can order like a plate
like a small plate of sushi for like a
dollar yes um
that still tastes way better than some
of the best restaurants that you can
find in the uk or something like that
yeah that's true
i mean the the quality of like because i
mean most of the fish that they serve we
obviously don't have in the uk
yeah but like even when you get the
salmon you're like holy [ __ ]
i didn't know salmon could like just
fall apart like this yeah bite into it
normally in the uk you know you get
something salmon you can [ __ ] [ __ ]
tug it away
yeah you've got to like i've had sam
when i'm like literally [ __ ] like
[ __ ] trying to stop it but in japan
right you eat it and it just like
it just falls apart yeah and it works so
good with the rice but yeah
man i if if i ever have like a workout
sushi is what i'm always craving it's
like the best post-workout meal i think
really cause it's like it's just filling
enough where it's like i don't want to
go too hard but it's so healthy and so
good for you
like man i really i feel healthy doing
this but i remember you were once saying
that you can't have sushi for dinner
yeah
which is weird because i i'll take any
excuse to take sushi yeah same as same
yeah yeah whenever these guys are we're
out there like you're asking a sushi
dinner i'm like
no no it's always what do you guys want
to eat and connor's like
i'm easy and i go do you feel like sushi
not sushi no
then you're not easy you're like that is
not easy
that was a [ __ ] lie it's like it's
like okay
i'm easy if you want to go to sushi
we'll go sushi i'm just going to be like
it's not a chief yeah kids well we don't
want to do that to you
for dinner because for dinner i feel
like okay sushi is great don't get me
wrong yeah but
for lunch i don't mind having like one
flavor
but for sushi i feel like because it's
all like it all tastes like fish still
at the end of the day
like yes the fish are different and they
taste different but it still feels like
i'm just eating fish and rice
which is fine but for some reason in
sushi to me it doesn't feel like a full
meal
but you know you can get other stuff
yeah but like when you order like fried
chicken at a sushi place that [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] awful it's like this it's like
the [ __ ] chicken has been abused and
like beaten up it's all muscular and
[ __ ]
like it's been in a [ __ ] fight club
before it was killed you maybe get like
one ounce of chicken breast and the rest
is like this black bone with like
veins yeah like holy [ __ ] what do they
do to this chicken
and then you're like what's the point
it's like roided up chicken yeah yeah
and i'm like i'm like hitting up the
miso soup like no tomorrow oh i'm like
stocking up on that it's normally free
not that i care i mean it just normally
tastes amazing yeah cause sometimes they
leave like
some of the fish in there they let it
cook yeah yeah it's so [ __ ] good but
i don't know it doesn't feel like a
proper meal i don't know why because i
fill up so fast on sushi
and then 30 minutes later when i've left
the restaurant i'm like [ __ ]
i'm hungry again yeah i i get that with
sushi as well sometimes where you
you feel like you feel like your
stomach's about to explode and somehow
like
an hour or two later you don't get you
don't get hungry you just like
get you get peckish you know yeah i can
eat a little more i can eat a little
more
i think it's just the rice that expands
in your stomach probably probably
and then once it finally settles down
you're just like oh all right
time for more food but yeah i just i
don't know i never understood why
you can eat sushi for lunch and yet you
can't eat sushi breakfast
lunch i mean normally you can eat for
breakfast yeah normally my lunch or
breakfast is sushi so yeah i can't eat
sushi for breakfast why not i can't eat
sushi for breakfast i can't eat fish for
breakfast
why it's just weird why is it weird
you're japanese bro i know